okay hi hello everybody uh my name is
David I'm a software engineer at meta
and before that I worked at a bunch of
different companies mostly doing big
data things because I'm a big data geek
uh and today we're going to be talking a
lot about big data but this is not a big
data conference this is a software
development conference and so we're
going to be talking about data tools
from the perspective of software
developers like I'm guessing most of you
here are so let's do a quick check who
here actually writes software for a
living
yeah that's pretty much what I expected
perfect
um so yeah so we're in the right place
um so what we're going to be talking
about is
what are the problems different problems
that we solve with data tools how they
evolved from 20 30 years ago to what
we're actually using today and how if we
had to solve this problem right now in
this room as software developers how we
would actually build these tools
ourselves and see if it's actually close
to what I don't really exists in the
industry and generally just see what you
know what the different tools are and
where you're likely to meet them in your
day-to-day work if at all right and so
before we start we can talk about what
is Big Data and there's actually exactly
two jokes you're allowed to tell about
Big Data the first of course is a
picture of Lieutenant data from Star
Trek next to a slightly bigger picture
of alternating data from Star Trek
hilarious
um and the other joke is a Facebook post
by psychologist Dana really from 20th
2013 and he wrote that big data is like
teenage sex in that everybody thinks
everybody else is doing it everybody
wants to be doing it and no one's
actually doing it right
and that was 10 years ago and that was
the peak hype for big data and at the
time that was very funny the thing is
now is 10 years later and most companies
actually have a lot of data and
everybody's doing big data so I stopped
telling that joke
so we're stuck with the only one
official data joke now
but really the big data is a field of
actually dealing with large enough or
complex enough amounts of data that it's
actually hard to process them with
traditional tools meaning databases
relational databases like most of you
I'm sure are familiar with let's do a
quick check who has ever written a SQL
query
perfect you're wearing the life plates
again good I'm just verifying that we're
going in the right direction
okay so like normal big data and normal
data tools are databases the stuff you
use every day in your applications
microservices whatever uh and at some
point we get to a place where either
there's just so much data we have to
query and process that normal databases
just don't cut it anymore or the speed
at which data comes in and we have to
ingest it and do something with it is so
high that again we can't just do that on
a single instance even the most
expensive and biggest database we can
buy and at that point we need to
actually use specialized tools but these
aren't some magical tools that only big
data people understand right all of
those were written by software
developers like all of us here to solve
a specific problem which wasn't solvable
until that right and this is a cycle
that happens in software development
very often right a new problem shows up
that you have to solve in an engineering
way and it's usually a combination of
economics and some different Trends in
the industry which change the way you
use data so for example the early 2000s
were a really good example of this uh we
had the internet and search engines
then a few years later we had social
media and a lot of people started
generating just tons of data all the
time
and the economics of it combined with
the fact that storage got way cheaper
generated a whole new generation of
completely new tools which solves
problems that you couldn't actually
solve before that
right and so when we talk about problems
and economics
we need to think about what is the value
of data right and this is a slide which
I really like it's from an article
written by by Scott Yar the CTO of all
DB a long time ago and he talks about
the the fact that the value of data
isn't constant right the value of data
changes over time
and it's important to see what kind of
data we're talking about when we look at
an individual item of data right so one
record or one row in a database one
event usually the value of this event
starts very high close to the moment
when it was generated the best example
would be for example let's see let's
we're working on e-commerce websites and
our item of data is a user's shopping
cart
so while we're browsing the website and
the user does stuff and updates the
shopping cart that object is very
valuable if you lose it we lose the
customer it's going to be very upsetting
but once the user checked out and used
the shopping cart and we log that in a
database the value of that data item
goes down very quickly five months later
no one actually cares about this one
record in a database however the value
of data in aggregate right so lots of
historical data for example all of the
shopping carts for the past six months
the value of data in aggregate starts
out usually very low because looking at
statistics of shopping carts for the
past five minutes isn't very informative
right but if you look at all the
shopping carts for the past six months
suddenly that data in aggregate becomes
very valuable because you can generate
Trends you can get statistics analytics
and business intelligence and you can
train machine learning models and all
kinds of stuff with this data because we
now have enough of it and it goes back
long enough right and so there are
different tools to address each one of
the sides of the slides there are
specific tools usually the ones you
normally use in your daily work which
are on the left side of the slide which
is tools that are very good at dealing
with small amounts of individual records
you know those as normal everyday
databases right your SQL Server your
postgres SQL whatever they are and
they're optimized to be very good at
dealing with a small number of Records
very quickly
and we don't really try to store very
many of those and if we try to do
aggregate aggregative operations with
those databases they kind of work but
they're not really optimized for that
on the other side of the slide right
when we deal with a lot of data and we
want to store a lot of it for a long
time and then we want to get value out
of it by aggregating getting insights or
running analytical queries on it
we have completely a completely
different set of tools to deal with
those because Normal databases aren't
actually very good at dealing with
queries that touch a lot of data all at
once right and so this brings us to the
idea of oltp versus olap databases oltp
stands for online transaction processing
databases these are the databases most
of you know every day SQL Server Oracle
whatever
all up from it stands for online
analytical processing data and those are
specific tools that are optimized not
for individual operations on records but
rather on analytical operations which
means a lot of data or a long history of
data going back
and
those have to be optimized very
differently and they have very different
economic implications because it's okay
to pay a lot of a lot of money for a
database which brings a lot of value out
of all of your data
and it's usually not as efficient to pay
a lot of a lot of money for database
which just stores some data for a few
hours or a few weeks
so when we think about what we do with
analytical data let's look at a query
right this query I wrote a thousand
versions of this kind of query I'm sure
most of you did too when you were
looking at some data and trying to
figure stuff out right this is a very
typical analytical query of data you
select some data you aggregate it you
know you count you aggregate you average
your max mean whatever then you join a
few tables together because you want to
touch a lot of data you subselect for
some conditions in the new group when
you sort and do all kinds of stuff right
when you look at it query as this query
it looks very simple
I'll give you a sec to look at it while
I take a sip
and the thing is this query has a lot of
different engineering problems hidden
behind it
so we'll go through them there's at
least four really big very incompatible
problems going on all at once in this
analytical query which is just an
example most another queries kind of
have all those problems in them one is
aggregation right the first one
aggregating data is very expensive
computationally and in terms of i o
right because unlike pulling out one
record from a database if you want to go
and you want to have the sum of all the
sales transactions in your entire table
of data for six months there's there are
very few ways to do this efficiently you
have to read all the data or you have to
read it in advance generate indexes and
that's also very expensive so this is a
big engineering problem uh joining
joining the data sets is an incredibly
difficult engineering engine engineering
challenge it's especially hard in
distributed systems where some of your
data is on one machine and some of data
is on another machine then you have to
bring one side of it to the other so
that's very expensive and very difficult
to do and we spent the last 50 years
optimizing databases to do to do joins
efficiently and we're still not done
um actually finding data within a data
set so your wear conditions and
subselects and sub queries that's a
separate engineering issue where you
need to prepare your data in advance to
be queries build indexes maintain them
and finally grouping is a completely
separate engineering issue uh where you
have where especially in a distributed
system in order to group data together
you have to shuffle it between different
machines over the network which is both
very slow because you have to go over
the network and also very complicated to
actually coordinate
and so
each one of these issues is a completely
separate branch of development and most
tools can't really solve all of them all
at once and so over time we've built
different Big Data Technologies which
address a few of these issues really
well and kind of ignore the others
because they're optimized to do
something really well so we'll take a
look at the first example
and I'll start with the story
[Music]
um
let's say it's 1980 and we're in a big
company IBM something
and at the time databases were not just
a piece of software you installed on the
machine right it's a big closet
appliance that you buy from
some company for half a million dollars
you install it in the data center and
you have a very very few people who can
access it and it has a proprietary
interface and its own data format and a
big enough company has a few of those
and they're not necessarily all from the
same company and they're definitely not
interoperable because none of the
database vendors actually wants to
cooperate with other database vendors
and your business analysts come to you
and say we want to take the data that's
in the sales database and do a report
that uses data from the user database
which are in different actually
different cities and owned by different
teams how do we do this
an equivalent problem would actually be
today right if you you did your best
architecture you you embraced
microservices and your architect is very
happy because each microservice has its
own database and you have your users
microservice and you have your sales
micro service and your inventory
microservice and now the bi people can
come to you and say well we want to do a
report across users and sales and
individually how do we do this like
they're in different databases
and it's the same problem because you
actually cannot do an efficient join
across multiple data sources multiple
databases and in order to actually solve
this problem the the new idea came about
in the early 1980s and it's still very
popular today which is a data warehouse
and the idea is very simple we can't
really efficiently join data and use
data across multiple data sources let's
just copy all of this data to one place
call it just a normal database but will
not let anyone use it in production
because what happens if you let analysts
run queries on the production database
oh
thank you yes it's going to be very bad
oh by the way just as a disclaimer I'm
going to be asking questions and they're
not rhetorical questions when I ask a
question my honest hope is that somebody
will actually answer it so don't be
polite
right I don't need you to give this
exclaimer in other countries the further
south you go the less polite people get
and so people just answer me sometimes
without me asking anything
but you people are exceedingly polite so
when I ask something I'm seriously
asking a question they're not sure
questions they're relatively
straightforward so please you know be
brave
so yeah what happens if you let analysts
run queries in production database it
lags it's uh it can be overloaded it's
going to compete for resources with your
day-to-day online queries and so we just
copy all this data into a separate
database we'll call it the data
warehouse because that's where we stole
all the data forever
and when I keep a long long history of
data in that data warehouse all of our
data is going to be replicated and
copied into one place we can run join
queries on it we can we don't need to
compete with the production use cases so
we can run very long queries without
affecting users and it's going to be
wonderful
of course you can just copy data easily
right you have to build some tools that
allow you to extract data from one
database and copy them to another
continuously that's a process called ETL
extraction transform and load and over
the past 50 years we've built I don't
know a million different ways to do that
but overall this idea
which is very old is actually still in
use today
so the the first uh place where that
idea actually appeared is a research
paper by uh Devlin and Murphy from 1899
which just explains the idea of a
business data warehouse and this was
just revolutionary at the time no one
has apparently thought that it's a good
idea to take all of your data put it in
one place and then let analysts actually
use it right
um and this is something that you can
still find today if you go out to Cloud
providers you'll find redshift in AWS
and there's a big query in Google and I
can't remember the name of the thing in
Azure but every cloud provider has their
own data warehouse or you can buy a very
expensive proprietary data warehouse but
ultimately they're all the biggest
benefit of having a data warehouse is it
gives you normal relational database
semantics so you have your schema you
have your relational data you have
queries in the same language in SQL
which is very convenient because
everybody speaks SQL
but it's optimized not to work on
individual records it's optimized to
actually run analytical queries a long
time
but it's not optimized to run many
queries side by side unlike an old GP
database which can optimize which is
optimized to run a lot of queries all at
once
and so this is very convenient and very
flexible but there are a couple of
problems with it
queries just take a long time because
when you run an analytical queries on
your past six months of data you have to
go and actually physically touch six
months worth of data in terms of i o and
this bandwidth and network bandwidth and
all that stuff and people are not very
patient especially business people who
want to get answers
and so a different way of thinking about
solving some of the challenges in this
analytical queries
showed up a few years later after the
the idea of data warehouses
and to explain this I'm going to take
another sip and I'll tell you a story
so imagine you're a software developer
should be very easy
and one day your CEO or some product
manager comes to you and says where's
the stable with six months worth of
sales transactions and I want you to
build me an application which when I
click a button shows me the total number
of transactions like a big dollar amount
amount on the screen
and I want it to be really fast I don't
want to wait I've used your data
warehouse and it's too slow
so go do whatever it is you do in the
background with your software stuff but
build me an application which when I
click a button immediately shows me the
result of the last six months of sales
and we're gonna we'll say we'll do it
when I run it to the nearest day right
so we'll Define a day as midnight to
midnight and I know some of you are
thinking midnight in which time zone
because you're smart asses I'm going to
ignore that
so what do you do I'm seriously asking
hopefully somebody will say okay
what would you suggest we do to solve
this issue
you have you can build any kind of
software in any language
use any hardware whatever you want you
just need to make one thing one button
you click it you get the result of total
number of sales
schedule is a good direction
what does the scheduler do
perfect that's a really good answer and
aggregate perfect both those answer
together
are pretty much what actually exists so
what we do is in advance because we only
need to press the button once before
when the manager comes to work right we
actually do the query in the background
when everyone's asleep and we store the
number the query is very simple the
result is just you know one float number
it's like 8 to 16 bytes maybe depending
on which language and which year this is
happening in
right and so you store it in your memory
and you click it and you show the number
perfect
and everyone's happy you put this in
production and a week later the same
manager comes to you and says software
developing person that was really good
remember when I said I just need the one
number so I lied here's some scope creep
um I want you to actually do this not
just one number but separately for every
country in the world
you think okay well that shouldn't be
hard there's like 200 or so countries
without getting getting political
um okay no problem what do we do to show
the same number but for every country in
the world
yes both of you are very correct you
just while you're doing this this count
you also group it by the whatever name
of the country for example and instead
of storing a counter in memory you store
a hash table right and the key of the
hash table is the country and their
value is obviously how many sales were
in that country and you keep the old
counter because why not you also have
the total number perfect it takes you a
while to write this and everybody is
happy and in a week later the lying
manager comes to you and says haha scope
creep
and it goes okay I wanted this by
country and I want this by month and I
also want this by day of the week and by
category of product
can you do that it's obviously very easy
right it's not a big deal and so it goes
on and goes on and essentially what
you're now building is a
multi-dimensional data structure in
memory which every Dimension is one of
these categories so one dimension is how
many countries are in the country per
country how many sales are per for the
category per day of the week and so on
and so on and so what we've actually
built is an odd up Cube
which is a multi-dimensional data
structure that holds aggregate results
for every possible slicing and dicing of
the analytical query and we run this in
advance because the thing we want to
solve is the the biggest problem of data
warehouses which is queries are just
very slow
and this idea was published in 1993 by
Edgar Cod and C Sally they can remember
what the C stands for but Edgar Cod just
as a side track
is a well-known data scientist at Edgar
code about 20 years before this wrote
the 12 rules for relational database
management
this was in the late 70s early 90s okay
so quick Story Time right before the
1980s
databases were just wild west there were
no relational databases there was no
standards no SQL query nothing like that
every company had their own database and
it did its own completely different
thing
and then towards the late 70s
query languages became a thing and then
the newest happiest thing was relational
database management which is you build
your tables and schemas and you Define
foreign keys to have relationships
between tables now it's a revolutionary
idea at the time and then every database
vendor who wanted to sell their software
slapped a very thin layer of
relationality under a non-relational
database called it the relational
database and sell and sold it because
that's what vendors do I used to work
for database vendor we're not uh never
mind
um
and so Edgar cudd who was a a purist in
terms of you know databases was very
angry with this
essentially
a disingenuous way of using the word
relational database and he wrote a
Manifesto talking about the 12 rules for
what makes a relational database and
that's still followed today if you go
and you look at postgres and MySQL and
SQL server and all those though all of
those are actually relational databases
according to the 12 rules of database
management
so the same Edgar Cod a few years later
was working for a company called Arbor
software and they created uh first of
all published research paper explaining
what an all-up user analytics is and how
the cube works and they built a
something called
um our word Essex which stands for
extended spreadsheet software
essentially it was a multi-dimensional
Excel spreadsheet everyone can imagine
in self-riched in 2D now imagine that in
five dimensions
if you can congratulations
but it looks kind of kind of something
like this obviously I'm limited three
dimensions plus time so that's that's
what I have but you can imagine a tester
act or a hypercube or further Dimensions
above that then that's the idea of the
of the olap Cube and you can slice this
uh this multi-dimensional data structure
across any Dimension and get
intermediate results of that Dimension
so if you slice it by year as the
example here we'll get all the results
for year 2004. and we slice it by
category along this axis we'll get all
the results for every year for this
category of product
and this is an amazing optimization on
data warehouses because it actually
gives us the query very quickly
there's obviously a problem
can anyone spot the problem
that's
first of all always true for every kind
of software but in this case also yes
you're exactly right what happens if we
have Dimensions with very hard
cardinality which means there are very
many unique values of that Dimension
imagine for example one of the
dimensions is the user ID and there's
let's say three billion users like in
Facebook
what happens to the cube
yeah because the number of number of
data points you have to store is the
product the multiplication of the
cardinality of every Dimension so if you
have very high cardinality Dimensions
the cube becomes extremely inefficient
it becomes not an optimization but
actually much worse than just using a
data warehouse
right and so this solution is actually
very efficient but for a very narrow set
of use cases where you have low
cardinality dimensions and and I I think
some of you missed it you have to
declare your dimensions in advance
because you have to pre-compute those
you can't just change your mind and
write a different query because the data
doesn't exist yet
in late 90s sorry late yeah 97ish I was
working at Intel straight out of college
and we had a an olive Cube it was a
Microsoft's all-up Cube server which by
the way wasn't a Microsoft product they
bought a company called called Panorama
software a year before took their
software and slapped Microsoft label on
it
um and we were we would build this Cube
overnight it took about six hours to
build the whole Cube and then in the
morning we would come and discover
whether it actually worked and half the
time it did and half the time it didn't
and so every day we would go and see if
the cube building succeeded if not that
was an entire day gone and if it did
wonderful we didn't have to do anything
so that's
that's two ways of solving
some of the challenges of this
analytical queries now those are very
interesting but there's something a
problem that's very common to both of
those
and that is the fact
that dark data exists
now what is dark data
some of you might have jumped to dark
web and no it's not data about drugs and
guns dark data is data which is written
but never ever used
and there are many studies which look
into you know how much dark data
actually exists and depending who you
believe somewhere between 50 and 90 of
all data ever stored isn't actually used
to provide any value nobody actually
queries it now intuitively I'll give you
an example which makes it very clear
think about application logs right every
application has logs
how often do you go and read all of the
logs of all the applications in your
production uh whatever it is
sometimes it's extremely useful
something breaks you have to go and you
have to find a specific subset of logs
for a specific time or specific service
most of the logs are never actually used
most logs are actually direct data this
is true for almost every category of
data it's especially true for machine
generated data so sensors logs all kinds
of stuff right the problem is you still
want to run analytics on data that
includes a lot of dark data and
what happens when you when you take all
this data and you put it in this very
expensive piece of software and Hardware
called the data warehouse or an olip
Cube
first of all you pay a lot up front
right because you have to pre-process
the data and compute the cube and ingest
the data so you actually have to pay a
very high cost in terms of resources up
front to even put the data in
and then because it's an online piece of
software the database has to continue
working you keep paying maintenance on
it all the time even if nobody is
actually querying it
so actually it's very expensive to store
data in all app type Solutions into the
warehouses
even if no one's actually using him
so what can we do
we can take another sip of water and
think about this
so let me ask you a leading question
what is the cheapest and most effective
way to store a bunch of data
sorry say again
compressing is good but you're way ahead
of us sir you're you're very Advanced
before you even compress it
file hosted file you put it in the file
yes perfect that's exactly that's the
easiest and cheapest and best way to
store data you don't put it in database
which is very expensive you just slap
all of it into a file in in a row format
and files are that's what they exist a
file system is really the best database
for just a bunch of data so you put your
data in a file and you pay very little
upfront because writing data directly to
a file in a row format is very cheap and
at least these days storing data is
relatively cheap as well right storing
data is I don't know if you go to AWS a
terabyte of storage costs 20-ish dollars
per month
right which is like my laptop has like
two terabytes of data on it
um so storing data is not very expensive
and the cheapest way to do that is just
pour all of it there in just a you know
row format into a file of course that
brings us to a problem why did we spend
the last four years being building
databases and optimizing stuff if we're
just going to put stuff in a file how do
we actually run the query on the data
and that brings us to data Lakes
so the idea of a data lake is
to separate two parts of uh traditional
database software like every database
you can think of it as two separate
pieces of software one is the storage
layer right that manages the software
and the data on disk the data format how
it's actually written builds indexes and
the second part is the compute which is
what executes the query run it reads the
indexes reads the data and gives it the
result and in almost every database
software they're part of the same
application they're the same piece of
software the network we could actually
split those apart and we move the
storage to the cheapest form possible
which is just bling files and we change
the compute part of the database to
understand files and read them directly
so we'll flip the economics over the
database upside down and until the early
2000s this wasn't actually very
economical which is why it never
happened before that
uh we had files for a long time right
but nobody actually used files as a
database or database system and what
changed in the early 2000s were two
things one search engines were invented
Because the Internet became big enough
to require storing a lot of data right
so we're
in the early 2000s we passed something
like 1 billion web pages on the internet
and this is just around the time of the
last round of search engine Wars is
everyone is anyone old enough to
remember search engine works besides
Google
yes yes Yahoo has to visit all of those
yeah
um so search engines were a classic
example of something that has a bunch of
dark data you ingest all of these URLs
you index them and most of the time
nobody searches for the web page that
you build for a cat right everyone's a
small subset of web pages
and so this idea of let's put everything
in the files and we will pay very little
upfront we pay very little in terms of
maintenance on storage because storing
files is cheap
because storage got much cheaper in the
2000s
but will pay a much higher cost when you
actually want to use the data right so
why do we pay a much higher cost
I'll give you a an exercise this is the
most classic example of big data
problems every Big Data course has this
as the first example it's called word
count
imagine you have a one terabyte file of
text plain English text and I'm I come
to you and I say build an application
which tells me how many files how many
words are in the file
how do you do that
hmm
perfect that's the perfect answer you
open the file you read it sequentially
and you count the why the change from
White space to non-white space or
whatever it is depending on how complex
you want to make it but ultimately
there's really only one way to do this
and there are very few ways to optimize
this for runtime right because you have
to read every byte because if you miss
any of the bytes they could be a white
space or another white space and you
would miscount so you read every byte
and you and you actually get a result at
the end of it
and
before we go into scaling out is there
any ways to optimize this for runtime
yes
I mean okay depending on the business
but generally yes
so just like one
oh chunk the file up okay and then
it's a good direction and you were okay
yes that's always the first thing people
think of it makes perfect sense uh the
problem is especially if we're talking
you know 20 years ago we're using
spinning disks uh it's actually not very
efficient to try and parallelize data
reads from a hard drive
because you're limited by uh the reads
the sequentiality of the read head uh
and the bandwidth right so even under
the most ideal conditions right the
bigger the most bandwidth of for reading
you can get from a hard drive is about
150 megabits per second with an SSD you
can get to 300 maybe maybe 500 megabytes
per second but if you have to read the
terabyte of data your limiting factor is
always going to be IO bandwidth right
there is no way around this
and so the only way to solve the problem
is just not solve it the only way to
solve this problem is to just split this
file into a bunch of different Hardwares
different machines and run part of the
problem on each one of them so obviously
you still pay as much in total bandwidth
and total CPU power and actually there's
some extra overhead
but because we're only optimizing for
runtime we don't really care as much
about resources this is really the only
practical optimization you can do for
runtime you just paralyze it to
different Hardware because the combined
bandwidth of you know a thousand hard
drives is a thousand times 150 megabytes
per second right and it is usually more
than enough to compute more than fcpu
and memory on each of those Hardwares to
do the task so the problem is mostly
bandwidth now this is the the core idea
behind the Dead Lake instead of bringing
the data to where your compute lives you
take your application the one you talked
about we write the application and we
copy a copy of this application to every
one of our machines where the data data
lives and we run it locally we bring the
compute to the data instead of the other
way around because usually the problem
is the bandwidth of the data
and not the amount of compute we have
right
and this idea was revolutionary in the
early 2000s and a whole giant giant
range of Technologies came out from just
this idea
and came about uh right around
2004-2003 that Google published two of
their most famous white papers the first
was the white paper about the Google
file system which is a distributed file
system super efficient very resilient it
stores a multiple copies of every file
across a network of machines and it
allows us to actually do the thing we
said which is the first part of the
solution right which is take a file and
spread it across a lot of machines
and the second white paper talks about a
new algorithm at the time called
mapreduce which is the algorithm that
Google used
to do precisely the thing we just
invented five minutes ago which is take
our application send a copy of our
application to every machine in the
network run it locally on the subset of
data bring all the results back and
combine them together those are the map
and reduce steps right you send the
application out you map your data and
you get the intermediate result and then
you reduce the intermediate results into
the final result right and this idea is
just amazing because it solves two of
the biggest problems that data
warehouses and olaps had which is it's
very expensive to scale them whereas if
you have you know a thousand very cheap
machines with consumer grade drives
in combination they are much cheaper
than you know a half a million dollar
Data Warehouse from IBM
and that colon Hadoop is the name of the
first open source system that
implemented this idea outside of Google
the two Engineers who actually wrote
Hadoop we're trying to solve something
that's very interesting they were trying
to build a search engine which could
index 1 billion pages
which today doesn't sound like a lot one
billion of anything isn't really that
much you know in today in terms of data
but in 2002 indexing 1 billion web pages
was
considered pretty much impossible in
terms of economics right because they
did a research and they found that to
index 1 billion web pages for a search
engine they would need a system that
costs roughly half a million dollars up
front and around fifty thousand dollars
maintenance every month which is not
something you can afford is a startup
who wants to build a search engine
uh and so they took the ideas from these
two Google's uh white papers and they
built a system called Hadoop and today
you wouldn't run into Hadoop anymore
unless you work for like a very very
conservative Bank
but there are different systems that
take the same ideas and move it forward
and Hadoop Quran the problem is
as it often happens with new
technologies
the first generation of a solution to a
problem that was considered impossible
before that is usually written by social
Developers for software developers which
means it's incredibly inconvenient to
use for normal people
uh you can think of it as there's plenty
of examples but in this case Hadoop
required you to write a Java application
using some apis
compiled into a jar and then use a very
complicated configuration system to
spread this jar across the network of
machines
run it on the local file system bring
back the results and the results would
be written to a different file on a
different file system then you have to
go and read the text file and that was
your your API for the data processing
system no GUI no SQL Server SQL query is
nothing like that
now the second generation of those tools
as always happens with technology was
optimized for non software developers so
they had a nice query language like SQL
and they had a GUI and all kinds of nice
things
and
today
we're actually going towards the third
generation of these kind of tools and
usually the third generation is actually
not even an improvement on the
technology but rather a change in
mindset set where instead of
let's think of it this way uh the second
generation of every software is usually
much more complicated and much better
but it it requires a certain set of
skills which few people have and it
creates like a new Mini profession it
happens when databases Revelation
databases come around and dbas were
invented it happened when devops came
became a thing and devops people invent
were invented and became like a big
profession and it happened around 2010
or so when data engineering became a
profession because people it was
complicated and important enough to have
like a separate mini profession just for
that
and usually what ends up happening is a
few years later
um
companies get sick of hiring all these
very expensive engineers
and what they want is for one company
like Amazon like Microsoft like Google
to hire all of these smart people and
build something that's easy to use for
everybody else
and this is more or less what's
happening now all of the Big Data tools
are now transforming to platforms
usually by big cloud providers or big
vendors and normal people like us can go
and just swipe your credit card and use
the platform because they have a nice UI
and a nice query language and we don't
need to maintain a very expensive
infrastructure on the back end right and
this is this is where we're going
towards like the third generation of
data tools
but going back to the story remember the
file we were reading
um so I lied when I say there are very
few ways to optimize reading the file
there's actually a lot of ways to
optimize it but you have to ignore all
the things I had said before that
so around 2010 or so
when people were trying to solve how to
optimize
reading files efficiently because that's
the cheapest way to store data
um
they decided that we don't it's it may
be okay to pay a little bit up front
to do a little bit of pre-processing to
optimize the way we store data in files
in order to make it easy to easier to
query we're not going to do a full
database right we're not going to build
the whole you know different kind of
database here we're not going to
reinvent indexes and memory caches and
all that but it's okay to do a little
bit of work up front to make the Brute
Force queries afterwards slightly more
more efficient
and this is why columnar formats were
invented now what's a column in the
format
um
Let's uh go back to another example
let's say that instead of saving raw
text in a file
we're allowed to change the data before
we store it in the file
how can we optimize the word count
example we had earlier
to make it easier and more efficient to
count all the file all the words in the
file
the only query we're ever going to do is
count all the words in the file how can
we change the application that thrives
the file
to make it easy to count towards
exactly that's that's an excellent way
to do it as we write the words we count
them and we just store the account and
at the end of the file just at the start
of the file some header and then we
don't even need to read the file right
we'll solve the biggest problem we don't
need to use any bandwidth or any i o we
just read the header we get the count
now we need to get if in the real world
it needs to be slightly more complicated
because we don't just need to count it
right we need to build a lot of
different statistics and read them in
advance and write them in advance and
then we might not need to read the
entire file because we can read much
less of it and answer the same question
and this is what columnar formats
actually do
the problem with this of course is if
you're going to do pre-processing you
cannot just directly write all of the
data to the file as it arrives need to
buffer some data to pre-compute it right
because in order to count it you have to
buffer some of it count it and then
write everything you buffered so
columnar formats and there's actually
two standard formats today in the
industry one one is called optimized row
columnar format or orc and the other is
parquet parquet depending on your
pronunciation
um and they both were more or less work
similarly the way the work is when
you're writing to the file instead of
spilling the data directly into the file
we buffer by default about 10 000 rows
and on those 10 000 rows uh 10 000
records of data uh in memory we compute
statistics on every field on every
column
and we compute for example from the
Merit columns we'll find the minimum and
the maximum and the average and the sum
and count and pretty much all the
statistics and for string columns we
might build a bloom filter or a
dictionary of unique values and once
we've done that we write the we write
the records into the file but we don't
just write them like we would in a
database
so the way you write to a database is
every record is sequential because
Normal databases deal with individual
records and the most efficient way to
read the whole record is read it
sequentially so in a standard database
like SQL Server all every data record in
a table is written as a sequence of
bytes in the file
in a columnar format we flip that around
we take the values for one column and
write all of the values for the column
sequentially then we go to the next
column and write that column
sequentially the next one the next the
next one and then we write we close the
row the stripe it's called and write the
footer which is which has the statistics
for every column and the reason we do
that is going back again to the
difference between olap and oltp
databases in normal databases we usually
want to get the whole record or update
the whole record in analytical
applications we usually want to run
aggregations and it's very rare when you
need to aggregate every single column in
your data like if your data has 50
different fields you're not going to
group by every single field of those 50
right you will usually do something like
select whatever name and count by three
fields or two fields or something and so
it's very rare when you need to read all
of the data but it's very very often
that you need to read the all the values
for one column and so it makes the most
sense to write all the values
sequentially for that one column and
then the next one and next
um and so if we take now we should go
back to the example of word count
how would we write a word count over a
columnar format we wouldn't even count
anything we would go to the index of the
file found how many find how many
stripes there are go to the start of the
stripe find the footer at the end of the
stripe read the statistics for that one
column which gives us the count
go to the next stripe go to the next
stripe some old accounts and that's our
answer we would need to run to read
maybe a kilobyte maybe two kilobyte of
data and it doesn't even matter how big
the file is because you only read the
actual statistics that are stored and
this bypasses the entire problem of
bandwidth
and you can also obviously do this very
very easily across a cluster of machines
because each one of those will do this
individually on the local files then
give you the result and we can sum the
results from every different machine in
the cluster into one one combined result
so all this stuff
was actually invented
by multiple different companies over the
course of very few years roughly from
2010 to 2012
and there are many reasons for that but
mainly are again economics and
changes in the way people behave
2010 and 212 is roughly when social
media became like unfortunately a part
of all of our daily lives I say
unfortunately even while I'm working at
Facebook
but it's you know Facebook and and
whatever it was before Myspace and media
and all that all the stuff that moved
online became big enough that it
required all of these companies so
Google and Microsoft and Facebook and a
bunch of others to write their own
version of these big data tools and they
all work very similarly all the ideas we
talked about columnar formats writing
file and reading directly from files
separating storage from compute each one
of them implemented a tool that does
exactly the same thing with some
variations they're optimized for
slightly different things but it's
surprising how many companies invented
basically the same thing
and again for reasons for economics and
solving a problem which wasn't actually
solvable until then
of course as with everything we looked
at
data Lakes have one big problem
and the problem is
you write the data directly which means
it doesn't really have a schema you can
write any kind of data and over time
data Lakes which is just the repository
of all the data you have in your
organization as just a collection of
files usually it turns into a data swamp
which is an official term
uh which is this is like the equivalent
this is the data equivalent of spaghetti
code right code goes from code to
speaker code data goes from a lake to a
swamp
uh which means no one actually knows
what's in the data Lake there's like a
bunch of files no one is brave enough to
delete those because they might be
useful
uh and over time you just get more and
more of it and the you'll forget what
the format is and the file itself
doesn't really have a schema it's not
like a normal database where you have a
table with fields and rows and all that
uh and that's a big downside of data
lakes and that's a big upside for data
warehouses and olaps because which is
why they still exist today right because
if data Lake was so Superior everybody
would just switch to that and abandon
data warehouses and all the other
Technologies but the fact is they didn't
because there are big advantages to
actually structure it and schematize
data it's much easier to work with it
and usually the people who pay the bills
which is the business people
listen to the analysts and analysts are
lazy and they went in and they wanted to
be easy to work with data
I hope there's any business analysts
here
I apologize some events
um and so as usually happens with
when we solve a problem in very
different ways optimizing for different
uh directions eventually
the different implementations start
borrowing features from the other if you
think of it it happened with different
front-end Frameworks over time different
Frontline Frameworks kind of borrowed
features from each other
different data Technologies also borrow
features from each other so modern
implementations of data Lakes usually
steal a lot of the ideas a lot of the
benefits from data warehouses and the
other way around
which brings us to this idea of a data
lake house which is a data Lake that
works like a data warehouse it's a
stupid name I hate it
but the idea behind it is actually very
interesting which is
if we give up
uh if we pay a lot of complexity because
usually when you have a hybrid
technology you always paid pay with
increased complexity but if we're okay
with having much more complicated
systems we can have the benefit of both
the data warehouse which is structured
data semantics which works kind of like
a normal database and also the very
cheap storage of a data Lake
uh and obviously it's something that not
every company will create for itself
because again the level of complexity is
exponentially higher but enough
companies
wanted this ability to go and work with
data easily but also not pay too much
money for it
and so
in the last three or four years this
idea of a data lake house became very
prevalent in the industry
and the way it's usually implemented is
you wouldn't normally build a data lake
house on your own in a company a few
companies like Facebook like Google or
Amazon have enough engineers and enough
interest to build their own data lake
house most normal companies would just
use it as a service because we're in the
third generation of data Technologies
and it's much more advantageous to
actually buy this as a service from a
company like snowflake or databricks
there's a bunch of them I'm not selling
any of those
and just use that as a service instead
of building your own data lake house
which is actually just combining a bunch
of Open Source Technologies in very
complicated ways
um and the advantage is
still not clear which is better right if
you want just using something very
simple where you can go and use a tool
like redshift on AWS or build your own
data warehouse you will get advantage of
having structured data you will have
asset semantics which is a database term
for having
for behaving like what you expect from a
database for being having atomicity and
having consistent data and having
isolation between data operations and
being durable uh which is something you
expect in a normal relational database
and data warehouses work the same way
data Lakes behave like files they're not
consistent there's no protection for
durability if somebody is modifying a
file while you're reading it it's
probably going to cause data corruption
and they're generally slower because
again they're files you're paying a
Brute Force query over all of the files
and it will take longer and they have no
schema so you have to actually validate
the data while you're reading it which
means you have to spend a lot more
effort in making sure that data is clean
and validating it and so on but it's
really really cheap
and it's very flexible because you can
write any data before you know how
you're planning to query it which is a
big downside of olaps and data
warehouses where you have to declare the
schema and create your cubes up front
you actually have to know what you're
going to do with the data before you
store any of the data with data
warehouses it's very attractive to
companies who like to accumulate data
and all companies like to accumulate
data which is they can store everything
and figure out how to query it later
and a lake house is kind of like a
hybridized version of both it's supposed
to give you both
and it's supposed to and there's a big
asterisk because like every good
engineering question it starts with it
depends how you use it and maybe it's
going to be more expensive because if
you use a lake house as a service
usually the services are are priced by
usage and by storage so you store more
data you pay more you query it more
often you pay more and it kind of
becomes a trap eventually
right
so before we finish I want to
talk a little bit about the future right
and give you like a little glimpse into
what I think is going to happen this is
purely my opinion there's no research
behind this mostly just experience
and there's a couple of spoilers I want
to talk about the first is what's
probably going to happen uh for social
developers uh in terms of using data
and the bigger Trend that's going to
happen I think in the next three to five
years is something that's called it's
called a data mesh architecture
which is this idea of instead of having
data be subprofession for a very
specialized group of people data
engineers
um build data platforms which are
self-service which would move the
ability to control data and manipulate
it from specialized groups like a data
platform architecture Team every company
has these days has like a data
infrastructure team or a data
engineering team or one of those and
those are the people who own the data
because they're the only ones who can
manipulate and you know use these
complicated tools and over time we're
going to see I think a shift
in data ownership from specialized teams
to normal software development teams
this kind of thing happened
in the last 10 years in different
domains as well a lot of companies now
started building teams that have all the
all of the different subprofessions in
them so you have a front-end engineer
and back-end engineers and a devops
person and a quality or automation
engineer all in the same team and a
product manager so they can actually
build their own domain services on their
own and not depend on anybody
and data is still the only exception
that I very often see which is you'll
have all of these people in one team and
a separate data team
I think life companies are going to
recognize that it makes more sense to
move data ownership into the normal
integrated teams as well which means
they're going to start using uh
self-service tools to actually give
control of data creating tables moving
data around over to software develop
developers we're really that actually
belongs
and this is one of the bigger Trends I
think is going to happen the other
is what I call biggish data and this is
not my term I sold it from a good friend
of mine
um
so if you remember at the start of the
stock we defined what is big data which
is working with data sets that are too
complex or too large to be dealt with
with traditional tools
and the thing is what was Big Data 20
years ago and what was Big Data 10 years
ago is very different what from what's
considered Big Data today
because traditional tools didn't just go
to sleep for 20 years
SQL server and postgres and Microsoft or
SQL server and Oracle they had 20 years
of Advent of advancement index and
progress
so the the standard tools we have today
are so much better at dealing with a lot
of data and doing a lot of this work
quickly than they were 20 years ago when
Big Data was essentially invented and so
the mindset of a lot of companies is
lagging behind what actually exists
today
what normally happens is
companies overestimate how quickly
they're going to accumulate data some
overly excited architect like myself
will go and say we're going to start a
new project and we're going to advance
and we're going to be prepared for hyper
growth our data is going to grow
exponentially because our clients are
going to grow exponentially and we need
to build a data Lake and we need a data
warehouse and we need a lake house and
we need all these seven other things
uh before we actually experience hyper
growth because when we do it's actually
going to be too late it's too hard to
add those things
and they overestimate just how much data
tooling they need where in reality most
companies have very linear and gradual
growth in terms of how much data they
have and how much their data needs
evolve and today especially with Cloud
tools it's very easy to fulfill most
companies needs
with just relational databases and
normal tooling
um
so how many people know what an exabyte
is exabyte
anybody want to say what it is
yes it's a shitload of data
uh but how much exactly
it's 1024 if you want to be exact
petabytes
is which is 1 million terabytes is 1
billion gigabytes one trillion megabytes
and so on right so there are a few
companies which actually have an exabyte
of data
Facebook is one company uh Google Amazon
maybe Microsoft there are a few
companies which actually have an
excellent of data obviously don't query
it all at once much more companies have
petabyte size data right the company I
worked at before I came to Facebook had
several terabytes of data there are
quite a few companies like that but in
reality the vast majority of companies
are in the terabyte scale one tens of
terabytes most normal companies don't
actually go into a petabyte range and a
terabyte is actually something I can do
on my laptop all right so I can actually
put a terabyte of data at home I have I
think maybe terrible 10 terabytes of
tors of storage across all my computers
most people here have at least like a
few hundred gigabytes in on their phone
alone right so terabit of data is not
that much anymore you can put a terabyte
of data into pretty much any database
that exists today you can query it all
right you don't put it on your
production database and run analytical
queries on it but it's okay to actually
think of terabytes as not really very
big data right the technology has moved
on
so what is Big Data today is not what it
was 20 years ago and we don't actually
need to run to Big Data tools to solve
data problems most people in this room
if I ask you to you know go build me a
data system which can handle one
terabyte of data and query it you can
just spin up a SQL server or whatever
it's going to be and use normal tools
it's actually a really cool database
called dacdb
collect the bird if you're interested
you should Google it
it's one of the new all up databases
it's an in-memory database which is
designed to work on a single machine and
do what used to be a big data
applications just on your laptop right
it can read data from cloud providers
you can load data from S3 or from GitHub
or from any web address or from local on
locally and we'll load data into memory
and run all app queries analytical
queries in real time very quickly
in at speeds and performance levels
which were just completely impossible 10
years ago and so today if you just want
to build an analytical application you
can download something like Doug DB or a
similar database on your laptop put your
terabyte of data here and just run
queries on it and it will actually work
all right so if you have any questions
we have one minute and 30 seconds
uh otherwise I'll be out in the hole and
I'm happy to chat about data wherever
you want and if not thank you very much
[Applause]